uh my name is swaad al-shireh i am a
student at the royal college of surgeons
in ireland and i'm 18 years old
when president vanderlian mentioned me
in her speech i was incredibly
surprised but also very honored and
grateful
you know to be mentioned by the most
powerful person in europe
and we will make sure that people who
have the right to stay
are integrated and made to feel
welcome they have a future to build
and skills energy and talent
i think of sweat
the teenage syrian refugee who arrived
in europe dreaming of being a medical
doctor
within three years she was awarded a
prestigious scholarship
from the royal college of surgeons in
ireland i've always wanted to be a
doctor
i suppose because the idea of being able
to help others when they're most
vulnerable that appeals to me a lot
along with the science and the knowledge
behind being a doctor
i could check the first line and i could
see that i had an offer to rcsi and i
i genuinely started jumping up and down
and i called my parents and i told like
call them to come over
and it was you know that one moment
where you feel like everything you've
worked hard for has paid off
and i genuinely you know my heart
couldn't stop
eating and i was just so happy
so yeah that was probably my happiest
moment so far in ireland
when i first came to ireland obviously
it was a period of great change for me
everything from the simple things like
the weather was different
but i met a lot of people that made
ireland feel like home
be it my friends from the schools i went
to and even my friends at college now
so i can safely say ireland is my home
and i am used to the weather
crazy as it may be yeah i'm really happy
to be here